Let's see how we can access the individual array elements. With arrays, you
don't call a method to get at an element. Remember with an array list we would
have called .get, but with an array you use the brackets and you put the index
inside. The values bracket zero, is the equivalent of calling values, dot get
zero. For an array you use the brackets. For an array list, you use a method.
You use the same notation if you want to store something, into an array. So
here values bracket zero equals 42 means put the number 42 into the zero slot
of this array. That's a little simpler than with array lists where we would
have had to call .set(0,42). How can we look at all of the elements of an
array? That's very similar as with array lists. Here we have a for loop. We
want to look at values bracket i and i goes from zero to one less than the
length of the array. With an array list we would have called dot size. Note
that length does not have parentheses. That's just an oddity for historical
reasons. We simply looked at all of the elements in the array, and as with an
array list, we can use an enhanced for loop to make this a little simpler.
Here's the equivalent enhanced for loop, over here is our array. We want value
to assume each of the elements in turn, and then we use it. Note that with the
enhance for loop, you cant tell any difference between an array and an array
list. You put the array, array list to the right of the colon, and the variable
to the left of the colon gets assigned each element in term.